翻訳: Maki Sugimoto
校正: Mai Iida
（音楽）
（拍手）
ありがとうございます
小さい頃 私はおとなしくて
コミュニケーションも下手で
友達もいませんでした
「ただ踊ることだけは
大好きな子供だったよ」と
母が教えてくれました
33年間 私は踊り続けてきました
休むことなく様々なステージに
立ち続けていきました
そして今日は ここにいます
辛いことや困難も たくさんありました
偏見を受けることもあります
ただ私は大好きなダンスを
ずっと踊り続けるために
自分を進化させてきたのだと思います
ダンスはただ 魂の表現だからです
もし「好きだな」と感じるものに
出会えたとしたら
大事に大事に 育ててみて下さい
好きな気持ちが育て上げた
揺るがない自信というものは
その人の一生の財産となります
私は 私の生徒たちが
ダンスを通じて 心身を解放して
そしてどんどん輝きを
増していく姿を見て
自分の人生における使命を知りました
そして一般社団法人
日本ポールダンスセラピー協会を設立しました
好きな事と言うのは 人間と人間を
繋ぐ事もできるんですね
私はかけがえのないことを
たくさんダンスから
そしてみんなから学んできました
これからも大きな大きな愛を
ただ伝えていきたいです
誰を目指すでもない
好きな気持ちを信じて
揺るがない自信をどんどん育てていって
そしてただ最高の自分を
目指してみてください
ありがとうございました
（拍手）